ciao a tutti sì lo ammetto anch'io ho
messo un paio di tette in questo video
come ha fatto clio perché vi starete
chiedendo cosa c'entrano ma
assolutamente nulla
in questo modo però cosa è successo che
il brutto porco schifoso più entrato per
veder sede magari movimento ha
contribuito il mio piano di conquista
del mondo
grazie mille clio di niente comunque a
parte questa piccola prefazione che ho
fatto bisogna subito parlare
dell'argomento del giorno sia san
valentino che non poteva non fare un
video sulla faccenda perché a boh non lo
so perché ciò poi va di parlare quindi
parliamo
cosa succede niente a parte che ovunque
mi giro vedo coppiette che sono sempre
di più così chissà ti rendi conto il 3
power san valentino a morena cioè che
per caso cioè che mette poi al regalo
boncio so per tipo mezzo pensieri ma si
trovi schema che sa fa contessa come che
setacciano gu dei fatti né periore di
tiffany un collier di ca piace ma ferma
un attimo ma che mi sto di slogan ma per
le mani o guarda che sarò di periferia
ma sofisticata sono s vabbè io
ovviamente non auguro a nessuno devo di
appartenere a questa categoria perché la
cosa sarebbe pessima
anzi diciamo che non vi auguro in
generale di stare in una situazione che
non mi faccia stare bene e qualora voi
vc trovaste voleste così troncare il
tutto non state lì a spiegare ad altra
persona i motivi per cui la state
mollando o non lo so il perché vi volete
allontanare semplicemente mollate
troncato ogni cosa fate finta di essere
andati su marte così non esiste avete
pure cambiato residenza se possibile a
sparire come dei fantasmi come sono
poste ma esistiti
vodafone l'utente dalla chiamata non è
il momento raggiungibile
la invitiamo a richiamare più tardi
grazie a miami e dall'altra parte se
invece volete conquistare una persona
secondo me ci stanno più tattiche che
potete ad operare rispetto al troncare i
rapporti prendiamo per esempio una
ragazza che mi piace che volete
rimorchiare adesso vi faccio vedere
quanti in quanti milioni di modi si può
rimorchiare ne parlo io
potete criticare qualsiasi cosa venga
fatta da questa persona nella speranza
di apparire strong forti con tanto
carattere e uno sbaglia essere così
attaccato a tua madre non lo so mi dà
l'idea di qualcosa di infantile che
nasconde un in sicurezza qualcosa di
irrisolto un complesso di elettra forse
sono potete non lo so complimentarmi con
lei qualsiasi cosa faccia sei sempre
presente nel senso tom aver bisogno di
te e tu speri è assurdo perché non sei
come tutte le altre non sei in schiavitù
egoismi e questo atteggiamento molto
maturo io ti amo troppo mina tela ma non
andava bene proprio sera ha conquistate
la con la simpatia ma fai bene a stare
con tomate però che ne sai magari ls per
l'iride sa se non cercate di essere
dannati siete magnetici in quanto
arroganti sta perdendo tempo molto madre
tanto però poi tutti abbiamo morire non
so potete poi saltare direttamente al
sodo
ho voglia di fare sesso con te adesso
conto male che ci vede disprezzate la
problema forse la ragione perché tomba
del timone così tanto accanto a lei
perché sembri sua sorella il lusso
figlia parlategli di un'altra persona
che vi piace amato madre insomma le
tecniche per conquista una persona sono
veramente tante siccome sono un po una
pippa
se ne avete altre potete pure scriverli
qua sotto visto che so che siete dei
piccoli casanova e magari se condividete
un po di trucchetti poi siamo tutti più
allegri e ne possiamo me
30 dic a qualcuno è insomma io prende
carta e penna
tutto questo per condividere una mia
stupida convinzione che ha veramente
poco a che fare con i biscotti della
fortuna e che ha veramente poco a che
fare con tutto quello che ho detto fino
adesso in questo video
se la verità è che in amore vince chi
ama bene che senso nel senso che pero in
amore vince chi che mai interessato che
fugge chi mette dei filtri che
fa lo stronzo e quant'altro però secondo
il mio modestissimo parere che non vale
una cicca del potere in amore non ce ne
faccio nulla specialmente se prezzo da
pagare è quello di armarsi di scettri
scudi trony scarpe da ginnastica che
sono tutte cose che preferirei togliere
l'avete capita dalle battute erotica
[Risate]
io la mamma non ce l'ho più